at CERN out live did so many great
characters you're one of the most
popular was your Kim Kardashian you did
a very popular Kim Kardashian character
and I think we have a photo of that card
there you go that's the essence of the
character I know but did you I mean you
met Kim Kardashian
I didn't it'd be intimidating to meet
someone who you've oh yeah I was very
very scared and she was really sweet mhm
I first of all she was in like pristine
like airbrushed makeup like perfect hair
and I that day looked like a person who
woke up in a dumpster like I I hadn't
slept in two days I was wearing this
like extra-large t-shirt with like the
logo of the medical facility from my
hometown she was like understandably
mortified to discover that I played her
on the show but was so sweet and she did
say at one point she was like do we
really sound like that she said that guy
and I was like no and she goes and she
just goes oh did you was ever someone on
starting out live I mean you were there
five seasons I think it was that you
wanted to play but you didn't get a
chance to play them well I was
constantly on a mission to play Aziz
Ansari on the shadow play is he's on to
for like a second it didn't really count
but yeah I well the producers were
always like hey what about this week you
play like a pretty gal and it was always
like or what if I play another small man
[Laughter]
and yeah I think we do we have a picture
of someone tell me that you brought
that's
[Applause]
we will do you one better than that I
guess you did you did a skit where you
played Aziz right it got ya this got cut
it dress
no one was shocked I was really pushing
for it but first of all it's kind of
disturbing he's like a very handsome guy
but me Aziz is like a real boner eraser
I beg to differ what I'm literally
short-circuited when he saw that picture
well we we found we got a hold of the
clip that was cut from SNL cuz I think
you do an amazing Aziz Ansari impression
and I think they'd like to see it let's
take a look well we have tons of jackets
all over this
[Music]
[Applause]
you